welcome back to another Monday morning
review with a side of spoilers today
we're gonna be talking about her I'm
Jimmy and I'm Jay s so hers and latest
offering from Spike Jonze yeah and you
didn't know he's great man he also
helped write bad grandpa which came out
a few months back yeah
so Spike Jonze obviously visionary
director has a really really good grasp
on these concepts that really on paper
it sound a little almost too abstract
sure sort of conveying film but he
really effortlessly gets the the message
that he's trying to he really brings you
into these worlds he really does the
John Malkovich and and with with her
it's it's really remarkable for for a
lot of those filament he was adapting
Charlie Kaufman for two of those I mean
he's an incredible screenwriter but this
time around it's something that he wrote
himself and it proves that he he doesn't
need a strong screenwriter to help him
because he is one himself yeah I thought
was the most surprising thing about her
so let's let's dive right in to some of
the cast in this film you have walking
Phoenix as the lead my favorite American
actor working today yeah and I mean I
have to say he is he is really amazing
but I think he's it shows this movie is
one of those movies that really shows
the range and he can play yeah cuz I
mean if you look at the last one he's in
the master he's really this tormented
guy down her he's just so optimistic
almost then I
I mean you know to a to a degree yeah
he's sort of like a quirky right LA
hipster kind of a guy
but yeah it's completely opposite from
always yeah he has he has much more of
an openness to new ideas and experiences
like yeah so alright my favorite my
favorite part of her though I have to
say is just the the journey that her
Samantha played by Scarlett Johansson
the way I voice takes and her sort of
evolution yeah throughout the film I
think that's I think it's done so well
my other favorite thing I have to say is
I love the the time period that it takes
place in because they never acknowledge
the date they never tell you oh it's 20
years the future 40 years in the future
100 years in the future it just is the
future yeah I'm not too distant future
right but it's a but it's very
believable too it's it's really
interesting I mean it the filmic please
clearly a commentary on today's society
our reliance on technology the roles
that it plays but the way that it's done
is not like beating you over the head
with like this is so bad it really kind
of takes more of a neutral stance I
think on technology's role and
let's you the viewer you know say okay
this is bad or this is good kind of like
today like some people might say texting
all the time is awful where the people
say phones smartphones are great you
know I think the way that the way that
technology is treated is isn't
reverential sure but it also isn't like
oh it's just a stupid stupid tool yeah
no and I personally believe that you
know progress in technology is not
inherently good or bad and I think this
film takes that same yeah I mean it it
sort of revels in the technology how
cool it is it just is
yeah right um you and I are both gamers
yeah this this movie has depictions of
video games what they might be like in
ten years from that I completely agree
with this depiction yeah it's fantastic
like this little like turd of a
character who's just like cursing and
walking Phoenix just yeah it's connected
like yeah he's like he's my own [ __ ]
and select this it's so funny but I mean
I think the way that the game it's funny
because the way the game treats him
it's kind of like what you'll hear if
you go on any Xbox Live
you know MMO or you know first-person
shooter you're gonna hear people just
like like little like thirteen-year-old
kids like yeah first thing about exactly
and really if that's what it instantly
triggered with me I'm watching people
play video games has never been better
oh yeah like whether it's in real life
or another movies like Ender's Game had
an example of where it's just painfully
cool watching someone play a video game
in a movie this is really interesting
yeah it's like it's like one of the we
came out and people were just like yeah
you don't you doing like the most
bizarre things contorting your body in
these weird ways but it also speaks to
what the whole films about yeah it's
just the rise of Technology
interactions with others yeah okay so
let's let's get back to Samara
yeah so first and foremost there is a
scene in the movie there's a sex scene
between Joaquin Phoenix and Samantha
that is pretty pretty remarkable scenes
of the whole year yeah
but prior to that there is a sex scene
between Joaquin Phoenix and he goes into
a chat room oh yeah
yeah it's with a girl named sexy kitten
he's voiced by Kristen Wiig and she hits
so we yeah he starts telling him to
choke him with his with a dead cat just
choke me with your dead cat over and
over yeah and it's just amazing yeah I
honestly thought the the writing and
this movie the delivery of the way
walking Phoenix played everything was
just so great it's like you could tell
like it was almost like it was really
happening and I know it sounds so stupid
to say but because I know he's acting
but like it was it all the performances
are so honest you know
I really I really enjoyed all those
moments but Samantha in particular has
this I mean she really has like this
full evolution of you know from birth to
you know puberty to like intellectual
maturity the almost this like we're at
this point where she transcends all age
and time and Jase and sort of blossoms
into like something even larger than
what she was ever intended that's true
yeah I mean how do you how did you feel
about Scarlett Johansson I was
incredible I thought it was a
groundbreaking voice and some people
have you ever been like I guess fine for
her to be a potential Award winner as
far as like Best Supporting Actress or
even Best Actress yeah there's some
controversy because apparently I guess
you have to technically appear on screen
yeah but what's odd is Robin Williams
was nominated for his performance in
Aladdin
oh really well yeah
Wow but I think there should be a boy
some sort of claws because it was an
animated film huh
okay yeah that does that interesting
okay I mean like what what was there any
any moments in particular that stood out
for you with with Samantha oh man even
from ground one with her first like
getting introduced like she talks just
like a person and the fact that he has
the most quote-unquote human
relationship with her than anyone else
in the film I think just speaks volumes
about it now and like apparently people
have been recently asking Siri what she
thought about yeah have you tried I
haven't tried I saw it this morning
actually it's pretty funny
yes series getting all pissed off yeah
which is funny you know it's very on AI
just start having a motion of another AI
that's kind of scary actually yeah but
no I thought Phoenix and Johansson have
great chemistry for what is like largely
just I haven't really seen a
relationship like that in the movie
before you talk about that sex scene it
cuts in black and you know it's just
like really great because we're in his
heaven yeah you know because like it's
the same sort of relationship it really
pulls you into the moment by the way I
also have to mention the fashion in this
film is fantastic you know they say
everything sickness you know cyclical
everything comes back everything has its
time back but like I'm wondering if it's
like this play on fifties fifties
fashion like super high pants I mean
like this waistline is like at your
chest there's a scene where he's walking
around the LA and everyone else is
running like that but it's like done in
such a way that's like okay holy
yeah being like coming back into you
know trend it's like the Apple
generation is whatever idols like
there's one moment actually that really
I think I've already had somewhat of
that
a moment like that which was when they
go to the beach and there it's Chris
Pratt and is it Amy Adams no I think
it's Chris Pratt's girlfriend yeah they
and and Joaquin Phoenix they go to the
beach it's a picnic or something and he
he has this pocket on his shirt where he
puts you know his phone where Samantha
lives which by the way I have to point
out that if you notice it's it's it's a
nice little you can tell like with the
way he is you know it's all about having
the authentic of the authenticity there
is something nice and grounded about the
fact that he just holds her up with like
a little safety pin yeah yeah this
agraria isn't very nice time yeah it's
like it's just you know it's not like
there's a special shirt that's built for
putting your phone right there it's like
you know yeah it's like a music of
practicality to him yeah I think this is
one of Spike Jonze the strongest forms
which is saying quite all I mean he
hasn't made a whole lot either but he's
one of the great American directors
working today
I really feel that way and this is
probably the best sci-fi film I've seen
in years I would say it's better than
gravity as a sci-fi film entry because I
think it speaks so much more to where we
are and where we're going well it is
it's interesting you bring up gravity
because I did have a similar feeling
when I left this film as I did when I
left gravity which is it's it's sci-fi
but with a heart and a soul that okay so
you know and not not to say that the
sci-fi doesn't have a heart and soul but
like gravity was showcased as this huge
epic you know sci-fi like visual orgasm
of just like particles and and all this
like amazing camerawork all this stuff
right yeah that's how it was sort of
originally first pitch to people and now
if you go in and watch the the TV spots
are running which for award season
obviously it's all these heartbreaking
moments from the film and all the
emotion and the drama acting and the
character and the heart and that I think
it it really works to flesh out the
world and I think her does a very
similar job where you have this it's
just sort of like a love story set in
the future that's true you know yeah
there's certainly room for both
an arcade fire did a great job oh yeah
of course amazing yeah yeah I think this
had a strong recommendation from both of
them yeah I have nothing I have really
nothing nothing bad to say about her
I've been looking at it like a lot of
Critics Choice like the top ten of the
year her more than any other films
appearing on just about every single
persons list topping a lot of them
actually so I mean it's one of those
cases where it came out of the doors
like in the last few weeks of the year
yeah there's just taking everybody that
I surprised I haven't heard a bad thing
about it yet so let us know what you
think of her if you did happen to see it
in the comments below any last words
no I would just go see it it's great
yeah please do that opens up wide
release January 10th so it should be
coming soon to a theater near you if it
hasn't already thanks for watching
another Monday morning review I'm Jas
I'm Jimmy take care